hey guys I am currently on a mini
vacation but you know what is back from
vacation it's not too deep my audio and
video podcast and this is our first
episode of season 2 is what we're
calling it to categorize things just
like society categorizes us as
individual this is the first episode of
season 2 it we are kicking off with
Miranda sings now if you don't
understand how the audio video podcast
works every Monday there will be a
podcast available on itunes and
soundcloud with my guests of that week
this week on the podcast is colleen
ballinger and her good friend Miranda
sings in addition to that on this
youtube channel where the will be world
we will be me talking me do girly and
also a challenge video with my guest
from the podcast and the challenge I did
with Miranda sings was the touch my body
challenge
what's that body part challenge
blindfold and poke each other challenge
it was a challenge so make sure that
after done watching this video you go
check out the podcast on iTunes and or
SoundCloud whatever you prefer cuz you
have free will this isn't of not too
deep is going to be very exciting we
have so many great guests we have
Kingsley we have Chris Hardwick live
Andrea Russett we have Harley Morenstein
we have Shane Dawson we have Kevin
Pereira and we have Nicky Lima amazing
people amazing times I think I've
laughed harder this I lacked I left a
lot of laughs a lot of walls you guys
lost below so get ready check out this
video and every Monday expect a new not
too deep right here and on iTunes and
yep hi guys I'm here with Miranda sings
today yeah yeah he was here and a part
of the podcast with me holding Bellinger
was here earlier and also part of the
podcast make sure if you want to listen
to that interview that you go to
SoundCloud calm such not too deep with
grace and while Miranda was here I
thought we'd play a challenge I thought
a fun challenge for us to do would be
the guest the body part challenge that's
one have you know Bonnie parts there
there have you ever done this challenge
yes I done it with myself before okay I
won that that's great I've done this one
other time as well so I think we should
be pros at this yeah we're gonna be
really good
Miranda's gonna be blindfolded first and
I'm gonna put her finger on different
body parts of mine three different ones
and she has to try and guess while she's
blindfolded what she's touching and then
I will have to try and beat her score
perfect make sense
very easy are you excited most excited
okay let's do this mm-hm
I need your hand using finger okay
that's a good part I'm gonna guess that
is the I know that was the skin in
between my thumb and my index finger wow
it's very squeaky thank waist thank you
that's like a fine like it that I'm only
says second body part
you better not be poking any porn on me
I'm not poking poor it on you the heck
what in the even was that it's not an
old boom
no it's by those your nose feels an
awful lot like an elbow I've reminds me
of a weenus I remind you of a weenus
yeah I don't bow holiness I'm sorry so
it means you're losing right because I'm
not guessing your part you're no you
actually you are losing but they're your
body part this that is true that feels
familiar
that's your finger no that was my elbow
y-yeah no nothing like Lena's I'm very
sorry to have caused that pain for you
so uh Miranda successfully gets zero of
the body parts right so your body parts
aren't good enough okay I'll take it so
I just have to try and guess one of your
body parts okay I'm so easy
okay I'm gonna ply my body parts feel
jealous link body parts and I'm gonna
win this one okay give me your finger
please all we'd have to pick a part
ain't kidding me yep what's in here I've
got a good idea okay hold on a second I
feel really vulnerable right out you
should
what is that
guessing hmm ah
I'm gonna guess an ear no what was it it
was my fingers with hair in it what okay
one down - no I'm trying to guess what I
want it to be poking okay ready
uh-huh up I'm getting a treat I'm feel
like I'm being tricked what is that what
is it hey uh it seemed like kind of
hairy and moist I'm gonna say your chin
when I was close my chin is hearing
moist - it was my eyebrow hair oh so
close
one last one is my last chance
what
what is that is that your tongue that
was your time tells me time I did it you
didn't I you can wipe it on me alright
thank you
welcome I think I won I won cuz you
guessed my part you won because I
guessed your part that's right Miranda
is the reigning champion yes yes the
body part did he thank you for playing
this game with me welcome I think that
um it happened it didn't happen I
remember yep and I hope you guys enjoyed
it make sure that you go over and check
out Miranda sings channel on YouTube
yeah and make sure you go over to
SoundCloud comm / not too deep with
brace to listen to the interview with
Miranda and Colleen ballinger and go
check out Colleen's channel as well and
yeah just cuz I'll take a second to
reflect on what's happened to today
smiling celebrate I don't know what are
like three things that you hate the most
right now
um melted jello yesterday I took out
jello in the morning he's like a half or
afternoon snack mm-hmm right and him
melting I'm so soon was just like soup
jello soup when it was warm